in this segment we point out and discuss
some important but also intuitive
properties of conditional expectations
the first property is the one that is
written up here what is the intuitive
meaning if you condition on Y then the
value of y is known and so G of Y is
also known there's no randomness in it
it can be treated as a constant and
therefore it can be pulled outside the
expectation so that's the intuition how
does one establish such a result
formally let us take the discrete case
so let us assume that x and y are both
discrete what does it take to establish
a fact of this kind we want to show that
two random variables are equal and that
amounts to the following we consider an
outcome of the experiment and we want to
show that whatever the outcome of the
experiment is these two random variables
will be the same so let us consider an
outcome for which the random variable Y
takes a specific value little Y and of
course this has to be a specific little
Y that is possible otherwise
conditioning on that event would not be
meaningful so if an outcome has this
value for the random variable Y then
what does this random variable do this
is by definition the random variable
that takes the value expected value of G
Y X conditional expectation given that
capital y took on this value this was
our definition of the concept of the
abstract conditional expectation as a
random variable this is the random
variable that they
this specific numerical value whenever
the random variable capital Y takes the
value little Y and similarly if the
random variable capital Y takes the
value little Y this random variable here
is the expected value of x given that Y
is little Y and when capital Y takes the
value little Y this function G of Y
takes on this particular numerical value
so we want to show that these two
expressions will be equal no matter what
Capital y is now when we place ourselves
in a conditional universe where capital
y takes a value little Y then the joint
PMF of X and y gets concentrated on
those values of capital y that obey this
relation so conditioned on this event
Capital y is with certainty equal to
little Y therefore this random variable
here in the conditional universe is the
same as this number but now since this
is a number it can be pulled outside the
expectation
so we have concluded that for any
outcome for which the random variable
Capital y takes this specific value
little Y this random variable takes this
value this random variable takes this
value they are the same so no matter
what the outcome is these two random
variables take the same value and
therefore they are the same random
variables now this is a correct proof if
the random variables are discrete if the
random variables are continuous or
general then carrying out a rigorous
proof is actually quite subtle and it is
beyond our scope
however the intuition is still correct
and the result is correct and we will be
using it freely whenever we need to let
us now move to a second observation
suppose that H is an invertible function
what does that mean that if I give you
the value of H you can tell me the value
of the argument
so in some sense Y and H of Y can be
recovered from each other if I give you
Y you can calculate H of Y but also if I
give you H of Y you can figure out what
Y was an example could be the function H
of y equals y to the third power if I
tell you the value of y you know Y cube
but if I tell you why cube you can also
figure out y so Y and y tube carry
exactly the same information in that
case the conditional expectation what
you expect on the average X to be if I
tell you the value of Y should be the
same as what you would expect X to be if
I give you the value of let's say Y cube
in both cases I am giving you the same
amount of information so the conditional
distribution of X should be the same and
the conditional
stations should also be the same so this
is again a very intuitive fact how do we
verify that this fact is true
using the same method as before so fix
some particular outcome for which the
random variable capital Y takes a
specific value little Y when that
happens this random variable will take
this value here that's just by the
definition of conditional expectation
this is the random variable that takes
this value whenever capital Y happens to
be equal to little Y in that case we
also have that H of capital y takes on a
specific value H of little why when this
random variable takes this specific
value this random variable here will
take a value of this kind
so this is the random variable that
takes this value whenever age of capital
y happens to be this specific number but
now the event that H of Y takes this
specific value because the function H is
invertible is identical to the event
that Y takes that particular value and
so since this event is identical to that
event the conditional probability is
given this event would be the same as
the conditional probabilities given that
event and therefore the conditional
expectations would also be the same once
more this is a proof that entirely
rigorous if we are dealing with discrete
random variables although in the
continuous case there would be some
subtleties involved however the result
is true in general the technical details
are beyond our scope